Jamie,
was it you that was telling me yesterday
about the guy who was the EMT who sees,
tell me,
tell me what you told me.
He's Ah, he said he was listening
to the podcast we did with Louis J.
Gomez about people getting head
injuries. Uh, and he has been doing,
I believe for like 15 years or so.
Like doesn't do it every single day
because you don't work every single day,
but on a three day basis or so,
every day he works,
he sees at least one person
dead from a head injury,
whether it's an elderly person
that slipped on ice or something,
people fall and hit their heads. Oh
yeah. Like that's why please folks,
if you're listening to me and you want
to punch somebody in, knocked him out,
please don't do it. Just go to a
gym, get your frustrations out.
Don't fight on the street.
You could kill somebody or you can
get killed at even accidentally,
even if you really don't hate the guy
that much, you punched him in the face.
They go unconscious, their head hits the
ground. People die all the time. I mean,
I've told the story about when Kevin
James used to work as a bouncer in Long
Island, a guy that he was
working with punched the guy
and killed him, right? Yeah.
Kevin.
Kevin wasn't there,
but he knew the guy and the guy
accidentally killed a drunk guy drunk.
I was coming at him. He punched him. I
guess I'm, I don't know the whole story,
but that shit happens all the time. I've
seen guys, it's not about punch though.
It's about when they hit their head
after the fuck getting hit by the world.
Think about that. Think of the
world. Just drop on your head.
That's what it's like.
Your body mass bouncing off a completely,
especially concrete. There's no
gift. So your head just clock.
It sounds horrible.
Why listen to someone's head bounce
off concrete is one of the scariest.
Fucking sounds horrible.
Even if you do it to somebody
and you want it to hurt them,
when you hear their head bounce off
concrete, you like, oh shit. Like,
that's not as simple as like you punched
them, you punched him and then you know,
whatever, they weigh 190 pounds
with all of the mass of grass,
the other mass and gravity pulling them
towards the ground with nothing slowing
it down.
But meat and head bang bone I shoulder.
That reminds me when I was 10 years old,
I was sitting on the curb and this is
the first time I saw death in real life
from a head injury.
I was sitting with my friend on the curb
and a guy was driving a motorcycle and
he was speeding up and down the street
and right on iris would and Houston,
Texas, he's flying down a
car, pulls out and he hits it.
Back then they didn't wear helmets,
so he literally flew up in the air
and landed about 20 feet from us.
His head hit first and
exploded like a watermelon.
And this is like, I was 10 years old
watching this. So the next morning,
you know the police come, my parents get
me to tell me, don't look at it too. I,
I'm, I go out there the next day,
it's just bless stains everywhere.
And his wife is picking up his
hair that's stuck to the concrete.
And I remember it so vividly.
I was next door neighbor was Eric and we
were sitting on the curb watching this
lady pick up her husband's
hair that will stop in.
And that's the first time I ever saw
death. And it, it, it was, oh fuck.
And it was a gnarly death too.
It was like that facing death stuff.
Like it was bad. It was bad. They never
wrote her motorcycle because of that.
Yeah. There's, yeah,
there's not a lot of reasons to ride a
motorcycle other than it's awesome. Yeah.
Just fuck the fucking danger.
I took a motorcycle safety classes
and then two of my friends, uh,
wiped out. One of them got hit by
a car and one of them fell, uh,
going around a corner and fucked
his shoulder up. I, uh, I,
after that accident, probably
about six years later, you know,
when three wheelers were big back then,
and my friend,
same friend that was on the curb,
we were f three willing and,
and where I grew up there
as bunch of ditches.
So where it going and he thought he could
go down in the ditch and come up the
other side, but I think he forgot that
his flat on the bottom of real ditches.
So literally we're going
and we hit the bottom.
And I flew up in literally half
my face was like, just wreck.
I was in the hospital and,
and we didn't have helmets at that time
cause we're young and dumb and just
wanted to like stupid stupid.